breaking news continues on the corona
virus outbreak the Prime Minister's
advisor Dominic Cummings is the latest
senior Westminster figure to self
isolate after showing coronavirus
symptoms on Friday it was concerned that
the Prime Minister and the cells and the
health secretary had tested positive for
the virus also calls the chief medical
officer of England and this comes as a
rollout of testing for kovat 19 across
England for health workers begins this
week well let's speak to our political
correspondent Kate McCann who joins us
from Westminster well Dominic Cummings
the most senior non elected adviser in
Downing Street and now he's got it
that's right we understand that mr.
Cummings started showing symptoms over
the weekend and so he will be isolating
himself at home he's still in touch with
Downing Street like the Prime Minister
like the health secretary and of course
Chris we see their chief medical officer
who you mentioned there as well there
are a number of staff in number 10 who
have come down with coronavirus symptoms
and who are isolating at home it is
understandably a virus that can spread
quite quickly among a closed community
there were lots of late and long hours
working among staff in number 10 over
the course of the last couple of weeks
so it's unsurprising that when one
person gets it of course a number of
other people have got it it has been
spreading in Parliament - we know Nadine
Doris MP had it a couple of other MPs
also self isolating because they
believed that they too had symptoms and
there were questions asked about whether
it was sensible to go ahead with Prime
Minister's Questions when MPs were
forced effectively to be close together
closer than that to meters that we were
all recommended to take but of course
Dominic Cummings is the latest in number
10 that we know of to be isolating with
coronavirus as you say Adam